[Music]
in today's head on your side Southern
Nevada home to some of the highest
rental prices for apartments and homes
in the nation during the pandemic but
what's ahead for renters for the new
year we check in with our contacts over
at rent.com for more insight
you know it's an interesting time right
now just because you truly don't know
what's going to happen in the rental
market senior managing editor Brian
Carberry of rent says if you were in the
market to rent a home or an apartment
you're looking at the right time because
right now Southern Nevada is following a
seasonal Trend generally during the
winter months prices are flat because
there's not as much demand a one-bedroom
apartment or house right now goes on
average for about 1374 that's down 11
percent from last year in our area two
bedroom is at a little over 1500 down
about 2 percent from last year but he
says there are some other factors to
consider as we get into the new year
there's a lot of different things that
could be at play you're looking at
inflation costs still up you're looking
at a possible recession and you're
looking at really the housing market
still being you know prices for
mortgages are still up significantly
compared to where they were this time
last year he says if the housing market
remains cool demand for home rentals and
apartments will increase he's seeing a
trend where people in smaller units are
already gravitating toward two and three
bedroom apartments as people look to cut
costs and move in with roommates he says
it's a big cycle as people try to find a
way to make ends meet right now we're in
a seasonal pattern prices are going to
be down but I wouldn't be surprised if
we saw them begin to increase again as
we get into April and May and into the
summer
net demand for apartments overall down
in 2022 for the first time since 2009
according to Real Page analytical firm
under turnover was also near a
historically low rate